Hace cinco años conocí a dos señores.
Yo soy el de la derecha.
(Risas)
Venimos de mundos diferentes,
no habíamos coincidido
en ningún lugar del mundo,
en ningún momento.
Con carreras académica,
en la industria, en la empresa,
en cuatro continentes.
Éramos un físico,
un químico y un economista.
Los tres con una edad más cercana
a la que la gente contempla la jubilación,
que en la que se lanza
a emprendimientos innovadores.
Sin embargo, once meses más tarde,
creamos algo juntos,
algo verdaderamente nuevo,
un mecanismo para decir
la verdad en público.
¿Decir la verdad? ¿Qué teníamos
en mente con esto?
La mayoría de las frases
que decimos en el día a día,
no pueden ser catalogadas
de verdaderas o falsas.
Frases como "Hola, ¿qué tal?",
"¿Vamos a tomar un café?"
son saludos, invitaciones,
pedidos, opiniones, sugerencias,
ni verdaderas ni falsas.
Por otra parte, hay
otras frases como: "Llueve";
"Son 365 pesos al contado";
"Esta casa es mía".
Esas sí pueden ser verificadas.
Me refiero exclusivamente a las frases
que se refieren a una afirmación
sobre las cosas.
Esas que cualquier persona
con buena voluntad, sentido común,
apelando a la lógica más elemental,
puede decidir frente a los hechos
si es verdadera o falsa.
Me refiero a esa frase que usamos
en nuestros contratos,
en documentar nuestros acuerdos,
en negociar nuestro salario,
en hacer compras, por ejemplo,
comprar un lavarropas.
"Son 15 000 pesos
en doce cuotas iguales,
mensuales a partir de la fecha,
para ser entregado en su domicilio
mañana de 14.00 a 17.00".
No hay ambigüedad, truco
o subterfugio que valga.
Dudo que alguien pueda
llevarse el lavarropas,
sin pagar, impunemente,
aduciendo que el neoliberalismo es nefasto
o que la objetividad no existe.
Convengamos entonces
que en estos casos los hechos cuentan
y la verdad acerca de los hechos
realmente importa.
Nosotros examinamos esas frases
con celo, diligencia, responsabilidad,
porque los datos que están contenidos allí
tienen impacto en nuestras vidas.
Ahora, eso es en la esfera de lo privado.
¿Cómo es en el discurso público?
Es decir, el discurso vertido
en el espacio público por políticos,
medios, periodistas, empresarios,
sindicalistas, referentes sociales.
El discurso público, últimamente,
--aunque ya ha pasado en otras etapas
en Argentina y en el mundo--
se va alejando de los hechos.
Los hechos y la verdad pasan
relegados a un segundo plano,
cediendo el centro
del escenario a la narrativa,
el relato, la opinión,
el dato sesgado, la sugerencia,
cuando no, simplemente la manipulación.
El discurso político
--tanto político, como medios,
como referentes sociales--
hace cada vez más uso de la narrativa.
Y hay una razón para esto.
La narrativa es poderosa,
simplemente al saltearse
el análisis racional
de los hechos objetivos,
nos pega directamente en las emociones.
Y desde esas emociones
nosotros subscribimos a las propuestas,
a las ideas de los partidos políticos
y de los referentes políticos.
El problema es cuando las narrativas
cobran vuelo propio.
Son poderosas,
porque nosotros pensamos así.
El ser humano piensa en narrativas
y no en hechos aislados.
Por ejemplo, Coca-Cola, utilizando
el poder de la narrativa,
vende 1700 millones de bebidas al día,
pero también organizaciones
sin fines de lucro, no-gubernamentales
logran desterrar la diarrea infantil
en regiones donde es endémica
o establecer en la agenda social
causas como la defensa del medio ambiente,
la igualdad de género,
los derechos humanos.
Cuando la narrativa invade sin embargo
la totalidad del discurso público,
los hechos y la verdad se transforman
en invitados molestos,
en obstáculos, en límites.
Hay que ignorarlos,
hay que dejarlos de lado,
desterrarlos del discurso público
o simplemente ocultarlos.
El debate tiende a desaparecer
porque es difícil debatir
sin hechos, sin verdades.
Así es como nos enfrentamos
a una situación
en que los medios,
los políticos y los referentes sociales
entran en una especie de rechazo
de su compromiso a rajatabla
con los hechos y la verdad
y de esa manera defraudan, delinquen,
entran en una especie de default
con su rol y su misión
frente a los ciudadanos.
Y los ciudadanos, inmersos
en esta situación del discurso,
vamos también aflojando
la intensidad con que reclamamos
el reporte de los hechos,
con que definimos y pedimos
que se hable de la verdad.
De esa manera, nuestra inmersión
en el discurso público
va siendo cada vez de menor tono.
Sin que nos demos cuenta,
inadvertidamente, para muchos de nosotros
esto es serrucharle
el piso a la democracia.
La democracia requiere
nuestro empoderamiento,
de cada uno de nosotros.
Depende de nosotros como actores sociales,
como agentes de la democracia.
Para ser agentes
dependemos de la información,
la información instantánea,
a la mano, dispuesta para la acción.
Sin información oportuna y verdadera
es imposible ser agentes.
Y para esa información dependemos.
Dependemos de los medios,
dependemos de aquellos
en los cuales hemos depositado nuestra fe,
y la delegación de nuestra confianza.
Nos hemos dedicado precisamente
a devolver al discurso democrático
esa fe y esa confianza.
Para eso, con mis compañeros
que lejos de jubilarse siguen activos,
fundamos esta maquinaria
para asegurar la calidad
del discurso público,
decir la verdad en público.
Fundamos Chequeado.com, un sitio dedicado
a la restauración
de la verdad y de los hechos
en el discurso público.
Chequeado verifica
las declaraciones hechas
por los agentes sociales en el discurso.
Toma las frases de los políticos,
los periódicos, los sindicalistas,
y las analiza en cuanto a los hechos.
Las corrobora y comprueba
con información independiente.
Las contrasta con lo dicho
por especialistas
y por fuentes idóneas e independientes.
Analiza la totalidad de la información
y la evidencia disponible
y así establece
si la información es correcta,
es verdadera o falsa.
Para eso, tenemos
que ganarnos la confianza,
ser leídos y ser creídos.
Chequeado tiene un manual de estilo
y un método de chequeo
que prohíbe todo sesgo político,
prohíbe el prejuicio, el partidismo
y demanda la existencia de mecanismos
que aseguran que así sea.
Chequeado tiene un gran número
de diversas fuentes de financiamiento
para evitar depender de todas ellas.
Dependemos un poquito de cada uno
de aquellos que nos hacen una donación
para no depender mucho de nadie.
Los estatutos de Chequeado
prohíben toda dependencia
y hacen que sea independiente
hasta de sus fundadores.
En estos años Chequeado
ha tenido impacto en la ciudadanía,
pero también en los actores políticos.
Hay ministros que nos leen,
legisladores que comparten
datos con nosotros,
hay periodistas que nos citan,
políticos que se retractan,
hay algunos que hasta
se pelean con nosotros,
pero todos, muchos,
lo piensan dos veces antes de hablar.
La comunidad de Chequeado está causando
que los hechos y la verdad
vuelvan a tener valor.
Yo soy parte de esa comunidad de Chequeado
que lo lee, que lo sigue
por Twitter y Facebook,
que lo escucha en radio,
que lo ve en televisión,
que sigue los chequeos en vivo
de discursos cruciales
como los de la presidenta,
que contribuye con datos
a la plataforma de datos colectivos.
La comunidad de Chequeado
prueba esa existencia
y prueba que la agencia social es posible.
Nosotros nos dedicamos a eso:
a probar que la agencia
es necesaria y posible
y asegura la calidad del discurso público.
A veces, la inercia social
parece infinita,
como parece infinito
el poder del poder político,
como parece imbatible
el poder de las corporaciones,
como parece inconmovible
el poder de los medios.
Pero el poder reside en el ciudadano.
Nosotros lo delegamos, pero no abdicamos.
Las causas ciudadanas, aplicadas
a causas justas y determinadas
han probado ser, todo el tiempo, exitosas.
El restablecimiento de los hechos
y de la verdad en el discurso público
es una causa crucial.
Una red de ciudadanos
resueltos a restablecer la verdad
como valor ineludible
en el discurso público podrá lograrlo.
Lo va a lograr.
Lo estamos logrando.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)